Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thank you. her old tradition of nationhood, Ireland, through us, summons her children to her flag and strikes for freedom. Having organized and trained her manhood through her secret revolutionary organization, the Irish Republican Brotherhood, and through her open military organizations,
the Irish Volunteers and the Irish Citizen Army, having patiently perfected her discipline, having resolutely waited for the right moment to reveal itself, she now seizes that moment and, supported by her exiled children in America and by gallant allies in Europe, but relying in the first on her own strength, she strikes in full confidence of victory. We declare the right of the people of Ireland to the ownership of Ireland and to the unfettered control of Irish destinies to be sovereign and indefeasible. The long usurpation of that right by a foreign people and government has not extinguished the
right, nor can it ever be extinguished, except by the destruction of the Irish people. In every generation, the Irish people have asserted their right to national freedom and sovereignty. Six times during the past 300 years, they have asserted it in arms. Standing on that fundamental right and again asserting it in arms in the face of the world, we hereby proclaim the Irish Republic as a sovereign, independent state, and we pledge our lives and the lives of our comrades-in-arms to the cause of its freedom, of its welfare, and of its exaltation among the nations. The Irish Republic is entitled to, and hereby claims, the allegiance of every Irish nation and all of its parts, cherishing all the children of the nation equally and oblivious of the differences carefully fostered by an alien
government which have divided a minority from the majority in the past. So that ladies and gentlemen is Professor Paul Rouse of University College Dublin reading the proclamation of the Irish Republic delivered during the Easter Rising. And Tom, two things strike me there. One is this is the earliest in Rest Is History history that we've ever had a guest in an episode. Normally we leave them waiting for about 20 minutes before we bring them apart.
And secondly, I think it's the most impassioned guest we've ever had because, Paul, as you got into that, you got going and going and going. I can see you kind of you were feeling it there at the end. It's an amazing piece of writing, a seminal moment, really, in modern Irish history. When Patrick Pearce walked out of the building we're in here, the general post office in the middle of Dublin and what was Sackville Street when he walked out on Easter Monday 1916, through the doors and stood afternoon in the middle of the street and proclaimed an Irish Republic. Yeah, and we are actually in the GPO now, being welcomed very warmly by Angus Lafferty and it's amazing to be here. It's an incredible museum, kind of wonderful display and statue, marking the very spot where patrick pierce stepped out
and dominic today's subject is really the road to the easter rising so we are going to do an episode on the rising itself absolutely we are going to go all the way back to the beginnings of the anglo-irish and unusually for the rest of history we decided that as two uh two middle-aged english public school boys we probably weren't the ideal people to um so paul we're delighted to have you on the show welcome to the rest is history i'm delighted to be here i'm as you know a fan of the show and i've listened to i haven't you nearly broke me in the world cup i haven't caught up since then but i'm a lot i'm a long-term listener oh brilliant so Paul, you wanted to start with
that because you want to use that as the jumping off point to look back at the long and tangled histories of Britain and Ireland. I suppose, I mean, one fascinating aspect of this is that this is obviously, I mean, this is Irish history. Obviously, it's taught in Irish schools, but we in Britain, I think it's fair to say, isn't it, Tom, that we are, by Irish standards, extraordinarily ignorant of this story. What I knew, basically, of the Easter Rising and of the build-up to it, I got not from history, but from literature, from reading James Joyce, W.B. Yeats, both of whose writings are kind of saturated with all this stuff. But I don't think I was ever taught it in a history class. No, me neither. We never studied Irish history at school at all, not one iota. And I know, Paul, you find that absolutely bizarre that the British people don't study this. I find it extraordinary that the events of a particular period in time, if we just take the
events of the Irish Revolution of the years between 1912 and 1922, 1923, they define the boundaries of the United Kingdom as currently they stand. It is extraordinary to me that presumably you didn't study John Redmond, then you don't know John Redmond's role in the people's budget and in the Parliament Act and everything that came from that. I think by the age of 18,
I'd never heard the words John Redmond or seen them written incredibly because obviously i mean it had a huge impact on recent british history through first through the troubles but then more recently through all the the kind of shenanigans around brexit and a lot of the discussion about you know should there be a border you know on the island of ireland i mean is going back to the events and the issues and the tragedies that marked the Irish Revolution. It was really interesting to be in Ireland and to look at the Irish reaction to English knowledge and British knowledge in general of Irish history at that time. And there was quite a lot of commentary about, there was a famous Channel 4 clip,
for example, where it was a Vox Pop. And normally I hate Vox Pops, but this one was actually quite funny. A reporter went out with a map of Ireland and asked sundry people to draw the border, where the border was between North and South. And it was really comical. But to me, it was run through with a smugness because the idea was, oh, the British don't know Irish history, but I would seriously question what Irish people know about Irish history. I think in Ireland, it's understood as propaganda, like history is painted in stripes of green and orange. And there's a cartoon history almost created of goodies and baddies. And of course, the beauty of history lies in its complexities and its contradictions and the absurdities of things that happens. And, you know, I always think when you get somebody who presents you history neatly
wrapped up in a box, it just makes me run with fright from it because it ordinarily is crafted in a way that is just simply wrong. Yeah. But I mean, history is obviously incredibly important in the Irish Revolution. It's the way that the revolutionaries understand Irish history and the history of Ireland's relationship to Britain that is a kind of absolutely fundamental motor in what happens. And so the way that the kind of 800 years as it's cast. So let me just read a 19th century Irish revolutionary called John O'Leary said, if the English had not come to Ireland and if they had not stayed there and done all the evil, so many of them now allow they have been doing all along, there would have been no Fenianism.
So Fenianism is... Irish republicanism. Yeah, but named after the Fianna Éireann, is that right? The kind of the band of warriors back in mythological times. Tom absolutely hasn't been preparing that pronunciation, by the way. I was rehearsing this before we started recording, ladies and gentlemen. So that sense summed up in that, this idea of there being a kind of mythical state
where Ireland was free and everyone was kind of bands of warriors, and then the English come, and it's kind of associated with a Norman adventure called Strongbow. Is that right? So who is Strongbow? Yeah, so I'll come at that slightly differently, but I will get to Strongbow very quickly. You have to think about when Pierce walked outside the GPO here, he had no popular support. So he was one of fewer than 2000 people who rose in rebellion out of an island which had more than 4 million people living on it. So if you don't have support of the people, where do you look for vindication of what
you do? So for Pearse and the people who went out in revolution, Ireland was not so much people, it was an idea, it was a place, but it was also a history. And what they sought to do was to walk themselves into that history and to become part of the history. They used it for their own ends, but they also now made themselves part of it. They were the next generation to rise. But Pierce's, I mean, his great enthusiasm is the Irish language. And Irish mythology. And Irish mythology.
And so essentially, there's a sense that he doesn't just want to get rid of British rule. He wants to get rid of British cultural influence as well. Is that right? What does he want? Does he want to go back to a kind of this mythic state that existed before the English came? What's the kind of the plan there? I should revise what I say about Pierce there. I think Pierce was first and foremost an educationalist. He was a magnificent teacher who was modern in ways that are, I'd say in terms of bilingualism. Pierce went to Belgium to see how they taught bilingually. He was a French speaker.
He went and looked at all of that stuff. So he was a very see how they taught bilingually. He was a French speaker. He went and looked at all of that stuff. So he was a very modern man in one way. But in the words of Aide de Blacquem, a propagandist for Sinn Féin later,
that world which they sought to create through an independent Irish state was to be a medieval fragment in a modern world. And that to me sums up some of the ideas.
So when they're creating this history, they're creating it at a time when the power and prestige of the British Empire is at its peak. It's not just military power here, and it's not just political power, and it's not just economic power, but it's cultural power. And their world is suffused with the English language, with English books, with English newspapers, English music culture, all here. English sport. English newspapers, English music culture, all here. English sport. English sport pushed all around. Cricket, the biggest game, Tom, in Ireland in the 1870s. So that's the world that's there. And so they look to history. Wasn't there someone who said that the Irish revolutionaries were the most conservative
revolutionaries of all time? I'm paraphrasing this. Yeah, it's absolutely true that that is said. I find that a little bit of an unfortunate statement because I don't think those two words really go together. And I think you can adopt a revolutionary position. You can do a revolutionary act in support of a moderate position. But the act of revolution is itself really, really important important so let's get back to the sort of deep history so they talked about 800 years i mean we're talking about their sense of history and their sense of ireland they talk about 800 years in the proclamation and this sense of a long history of oppression which is i'm guessing the sense that most of our listeners will bring
to this podcast this idea that the island has been under the english i mean specifically english but it's complicated because when the barons are coming over strongbow and co i mean they're not that Ireland has been under the English, I mean, specifically English, But it's complicated because when the barons are coming over, Strongbow and co, I mean, they're not actually English. So where should we kick off this? Well, where you start any history story or where you end, as you know,
is exceptionally difficult. Do we start it with the story of the first people who arrived in Ireland 10,000 years ago? Or do we go to Trahulaf, Donegal, the rock that archaeologists have dated 17 million years ago? Or do we go to Trahulof, Donegal, the rock that archaeologists have dated 17 million years ago? Or do we come forward
to the Cajafields, that kind of old farm structure 6,000 years ago and down along the coast of Mayo? Do we talk about the Vikings in the 1790s? The founders of Dublin. Exactly.
And so where do you start? I mean, so just on that point, the Vikings, right? If you want to, I mean, if we're talking about that, at that point, what are Ireland and England are quite closely intertwined, aren't they? I mean, so just on that point, the Vikings, right? If you want to, I mean, if we're talking about that, at that point, what are Ireland and England are quite closely intertwined, aren't they? I mean, there are kingdoms across both islands.
So the King of Dublin is also the King of York. Yes. And for 300 years, Viking culture clearly makes modern towns in Ireland. It has a huge press across the countryside. There's intermarriage and there's interrelationship with Irish people everywhere. There's trade and commerce and language shared. And the marks of that are still here in road structures that you can see from that period the forwarding of the Liffey for example and the way the roads come to it in Dublin
is clearly a remnant of that period so the mark of Viking impress in some of the words and language and names are still visible in Dublin today. But specifically this 800 years idea and this figure of Strongbow, is he English? Who is he? What's he doing coming here? Okay. So 800 years is thrown around from 1969
to start the Troubles, which very conveniently is the 800 years back to 1169, which is the arrival of these lords, the Fitzsievans, the Fitzgeralds and the de Burghs, who come to Ireland in 1169. They're followed the following year by Strongbow, who's the Earl of Pembroke, Richard Fitzgilbert. And they're there, invited to come over by a local lord. And I was really struck when Martin Johns was on here talking about Wales, about lords being invited into
different places to be part of a local conflict. But what matters here is the following year, 1171, King Henry II came over because he could see the power that was developing through these lords who had come to Ireland and had now taken hold. And he knew he was uncertain in his own position at the time. So he came to Dublin, spent six months in Ireland with 4,000 foot soldiers and 500 knights and basically took Dublin, Wexford, Watford as his royal domain. And he let his English barons or Norman, whatever name you want to call them. It's complex, isn't it? Because it does modulate the idea that it's just continuously English. They refer to themselves as English. Tom Barclay is really clear about this in his long history of Ireland
that they call themselves English at this period. And they were given lands around that area. But there was another power in the land still there. And this too matters. It's Rurio Corrur, who's king of Connacht. So the Gaelic lords are left in place, or the Gaelic chieftains are left in place in certain places. This is an absolutely incomplete conquest. In fact, to call it conquest at all is too much. These are rival powers across the land and it changes over time. So you see in 1204, King John comes back and 1204 is Dublin Castle, the seat of British, inverted commas, British stroke English rule in Ireland over the next 700 years and longer. And Paul, just to clarify for some of our listeners, at this point, there is no, as it were,
united Irish kingdom and there never has been. Am I right? Or it's been much more of a patchwork? Yeah, and this is where it gets complicated and it's interesting. There is a High King and there's the place of Tara and there's all of that, but these are moving. This is moving parts.
And in the construction of a history in the 19th century, late 19th and early 20th century, there's this imagination that everything was peaceful and thriving and it was ideal. And the Irish did things like, for example, it was said the Irish invented chess and gave to the world and that the 32 pieces of the chess set were actually modeled on the 32 counties of Ireland. Yeah, I'm a tiny be sceptical about that. There is a book called How the Irish Invented Chess! It may not be one to go with. But on top of that, there's this idea
that the Irish Talchin Games, which were a real event of athletics and horse racing and all that, according to Irish nationalists, T.H. Nally
actually wrote this in a book called The End of Talchin. T.H. Nally was a playwright who had a play about to be staged on the Abbey Theatre on Easter Monday 1916. It was never staged.
How unlucky was that man? But he wrote a book on The Enoch Talchin which said that these old games of the Irish were the inspiration of the Greek Olympics. But this is what people, these people weren't stupid. They weren't stupid when they said these things.
They're creating a mythology and a history and a counterpoint to British imperial culture. People are always doing that. I mean, so we've talked about this actually in the episode we did on British coronations,
that the Stone of Scone is supposed to have originally stood at Tara and the High Kings of Ireland be crowned on it and to have been brought by Scotta, who was variously the daughter of Pharaoh or the daughter of the King of Israel or whatever.
So this idea of constructing strange backstories has been a kind of continuous process. I mean, not just through Irish history, through all the history, people are endlessly doing it. It's the way it works. And what the Irish nationalists did have, though, is they had something different than any other nation had at that point. They had an old vernacular literature written in early Irish, which was written between the 7th century and the 17th century, written in Irish monasteries, which were stories of the annals of Ireland, had the old laws included, had these stories, this kind of heroic literature written into it, written in a different language. And that really matters because it spoke to the idea of an ancient civilization, an antiquity which predates the arrival of Strongbow and King Henry II.
And indeed Christianity. So it's a pre-Christian culture. But then you have the overlay of Christian culture. So the saints of early Ireland are incredibly powerful. I mean, they go to England, they go to France, they... Yeah, it's Iona, it's St. Columba, it's the Western Isles, it's everything. So hence, you know, How the Irish Saved Civilization. Like another book. Yeah, another book. So that idea as well. And that becomes important. So throughout the Middle Ages, there is an English outpost in Dublin which the pale beyond the pale
remains Irish and the English hold on and occasionally they worry that they're going to be absorbed into Irish culture and so they kind of notorious statutes of Kilkenny which tries to impose specifically English identity
on the English colonists they have to speak English they ban Irish entertainers. So Graham Norton would have been banned under the statues of Gilkenny. But the English are there. But then what complicates the issue further is the fact that in the 16th century, the English, and indeed the Scots, turn Protestant. Yes. And the Irish don't.
So just before we come to that, Paul, just one last word on the Middle Ages, if I may. At that point, is it reasonable to talk about English oppression? So in other words, Strongbow and his descendants and the Norman barons and then the English who are in Dublin and all that stuff, is this genuinely part of a long history of the English boot, as it were? Or at that point, is that just absolutely standard medieval stuff?
I mean, of course, the English are fighting the Hundred Years' War and they're doing all these other things and, you know, Europe is a violent place. Is this unusual at that point? I don't think it's unusual. I think it's part of a wider platform, but it is unique onto Ireland,
what happens in Ireland. And that's how it is understood. Now, we have to be clear about this. There was a pale between what was the English lordship. There was a pale between what was the English lordship. There were the Anglo-Norman, or English, or Norman,
or what became Anglo-Irish, who had their lordships around the place, who were their own power. And then you had the Gailey chieftains, as we've said. But culture doesn't work in a way that there are silos between people. The line of the pale was easily traversed. There was Irish spoken on both sides of that pale.
So hence the statues of Kilkenny. Exactly. There were games played across the pale. And that's why the statues are brought in. But this is a waxing and waning of English power. Now, I think it really matters, though, that if you look at it, no English king came back to Ireland for more than 200 years. So that tells you that Ireland didn't really matter. So Richard II came back in 1394.
It didn't work out well for him. It didn't work out great. But if you go back before that, it's King John. You go after Richard II, it is not till the end of the 17th century that James and William come to Ireland and Ireland becomes a theatre of European war. Yeah. So this is not central to what is happening in England. And to people in Ireland
at that point, would they have a consciousness of being oppressed? I don't think it works like that. I think it depends on who you are. I think if you've lost, if you don't have power, it doesn't matter if your power,
you're not important. If your power is held by a Gaelic chieftain or if it's held by an English lord or an Anglo-Irish lord, you don't have power. What does matter, however,
is the manner in which the Irish exchequer was plundered by English kings. So, for example, Irish law, you don't have power. What does matter, however, is the manner in which the Irish Exchequer was plundered by English kings. So, for example, you have Henry III taking all the monies from the Irish Exchequer to fund his wars in France and in the Middle East. So that
matters. What's the constitutional arrangement then? So is the English Crown claiming the whole island of Ireland? No, it claims its lordship. It claims a lordship of Ireland. So when does the English Crown claim the whole of Ireland? If you look at it, you get a transformation under Henry VIII in the 1540s when his royal title in 1541 was changed from Lord of Ireland to King of Ireland. And so is this bundled in with the religious reformation? It's part of the reformation. And then we move from reformation into land, into conquest of land, and you get land and religion and identity.
So it's really under the Tudors. The English crown claims the kingship of Ireland and also England becomes Protestant. And so that therefore sharpens religious differences between Britain and Ireland. Yes. And it's a product of a span of 150 years, the 1540s and the 1690s, this increasing encroachment, its conquest, its colonization, and it's an attempt at reformation. So you say an attempt at reformation. So let's just go with that for a second, because that's the thing that kind of looms very large obviously the religious issue why no reformation in ireland i mean that's you know scotland wales the one part of the tudor lands right where the reformation failed what i was about to say what went wrong but you wouldn't say it that way i'm an atheist i'm i'm I can take it either ways.
A Catholic or a Protestant atheist. The ultimate Irish question. But in Why the Reformation Failed in Ireland, you will not be surprised to know that there are long, extensive, and very detailed disputes between historians as to why precisely the Reformation failed in Ireland. There is an argument that the
Irish church was not quite as venal as churches everywhere, so therefore it didn't need to be reformed quite as well. But to me, when you read the material from the period, when you go back and you look at everything, repeatedly, the extent to which people struggle to understand just quite how central religion was to identity in that period. So land ownership is wealth. Right. If you put in a series of laws, ultimately, which tie land ownership to religion. Yeah. ownership to religion. And if you have position like place and all around this, you have England at war with France, at war with Spain at various junctures and trying to keep the back door shut because of the view that Catholic France or Catholic Spain will ally with the Catholics
in Ireland who are of not just uncertain loyalty, who are absolutely disloyal when it comes to religion. But equally for the Irish, the fact that they suddenly find themselves constitutionally subordinate to a foreign crown and that that foreign crown is religiously different must sharpen their sense of being Catholic rather than Protestant. And so the two kind of go together. It works together. And if you ask the question about that sense of oppression and that sense of exclusion and you can see it through these years and you can see it through the exclusion from positions of privilege and of political power you can see it through the loss of economic power you can see it through a long dispossession of land is it also that am i right in thinking now this may be my ignorance so absolutely correct
me if i'm wrong am i right in thinking that, so Protestantism in England, there are people with links with the continent, there are traders, merchant, the book trade and so on. You know, it spreads through mercantile, ambitious, aspirational kind of town people. Am I right in thinking in Ireland there will be fewer towns? And that is also surely, you know, it's a much more rural economy rural economy and so for that reason it's harder for Protestantism to spread there's maybe less of a book trade there are less of the the urban environments in which ideas can be exchanged and
so on yes I think that really matters and the second point that I would tie to that is the idea of language and the Irish language spoken across a large swath of the population, many of whom remain Catholic. No preachers coming from England who are associated with the people who took the land from them, unable to. And the Book of Common Prayer is only belatedly translated into Irish, which matters too. So you have language as well at issue. So Paul, you mentioned colonization. So that is also a part of what happens in the Tudor period and into the Stuart period. I think we should take a break at this point. When we come back, perhaps we could talk about specifically the settlement of Protestants in Ireland, because of course, this will have a seismic impact on subsequent Irish and indeed British history.
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. dot com Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are looking at 800 years of Irish history and
specifically Ireland's relationship to England but also Paul to Scotland. So the Scots are also involved in the process of colonisation which happens towards the end of the 16th century. And so therefore, because the part of Ireland that is closest to Scotland is Ulster, it's Ulster that is the particular focus for settlement and colonisation by Protestants. So just talk us through a bit about what happens there. Okay, so this is where we get in to the enduring divides of Ireland and how it extends beyond
politics and political power, economic power. It ties a political power and economic power into it, but it's also cultural power and ideas of identity with religion run through them. It is about a reformation which fails, but it's also about land ownership at its core. And it's about security. What I mean by security is this idea that one of the ideas of planting Ireland, that is to say, taking land, dispossessing people who own it and giving it to settlers, is the idea of making Ireland safe, that it is no longer a threat to the crown. Because this will become the model for the settlement plantations in the new world as well. Yes. And it really matters that it began in the 1560s, 1570s, into the 1690s. Two thirds of the land of Ireland was taken from natives and given to settlers. So this is dispossession on an epic scale. And there are about 100,000 such settlers who come from England
政治与政治权力、经济权力。它将政治权力和经济权力交织在一起，但也涉及文化权力和贯穿其中的宗教认同观念。这是一场失败的宗教改革，但其核心也是土地所有权问题。并且它关乎安全。我所说的安全是指这样一种观点：开辟爱尔兰殖民地（即夺取土地、剥夺原土地所有者的财产并将其分配给殖民者）的想法之一，就是为了让爱尔兰变得安全，使其不再对王权构成威胁。因为这将成为新世界定居点殖民地的模范。是的。而且，它始于16世纪60年代、70年代并一直延续到17世纪90年代，这一点至关重要。爱尔兰三分之二的土地被从原住民手中夺走并分给了殖民者。所以这是一场空前规模的财产剥夺。大约有10万名这样的殖民者来自英格兰
and Scotland. Mainly Scotland or mainly? No, a mix between the two. But there are about 100,000 such settlers who come from England and Scotland. Mainly Scotland or mainly? No, a mix between the two. But there's also land given to soldiers who fight in the armies and there's land given to people who are in Ireland already and who are given land, which if they're of certain loyalty to the crown. In the course of this, the landscape of Ireland was fundamentally changed. The language of Ireland began to significantly change. And the plantations ultimately were about two things. As well as religion, they were about security and about profit. And that matters. And in their form, they began with the Leek's Offaly plantation, Offaly being the cradle of civilization, enduringly. You may guess that that's where I'm from. In the 1570s, which largely failed. It was land taken from the O'Connors and the O'Moores,
和苏格兰。主要是苏格兰还是主要是？不，两者兼有。不过大约有10万名这样的殖民者来自英格兰和苏格兰。主要是苏格兰还是主要是？不，两者兼有。但也有土地分给在军队中作战的士兵，还有土地分给了已经身在爱尔兰且对王权表现出一定忠诚的人。在此过程中，爱尔兰的地貌发生了根本性的变化。爱尔兰的语言也开始发生显着变化。殖民地归根结底关乎两件事。除了宗教，它们还关乎安全和利益。这很重要。就其形式而言，它们始于利克斯和奥法利殖民地，奥法利长期以来一直是文明的发源地。你可能会猜到我是那里人。在16世纪70年代，这在很大程度上是失败的。那是从奥康纳和奥莫尔家族手中夺取的土地，
but it didn't really work. There was then an attempt after a Desmond rebellion against English rule in the 1590s. There was an attempt to settle Munster, which itself largely failed. But then we get the Ulster plantations, both private plantations where people came over and plantations by the crown.
但它并没有真正起作用。随后，在16世纪90年代针对英国统治的德斯蒙德叛乱之后，曾有过一次尝试。尝试对芒斯特进行殖民，但本身也在很大程度上失败了。但随后我们迎来了阿尔斯特殖民地，既有人们迁徙过来的私人殖民地，也有王室建立的殖民地。
So you said about security. So there's obviously no coincidence that this is the point. What is it? You said 1560s, 1570s. This is the point when, you know, Elizabeth I is extremely anxious about the threat from Catholic Spain. And presumably that plays a huge part in the mentality of the authorities. They think a Spanish landing or whatever it might be, a Spanish fermented rebellion in Ireland might then spread to England. And actually, now that I think about it, I mean, there is a history of people. I mean, I don't know, your Lambert, Simnels and your Perkin, Warbecks
所以你刚才提到了安全。因此，这显然并非巧合。那是什么时候？你说是16世纪60年代、70年代。这就是你知道的，伊丽莎白一世对来自天主教西班牙的威胁感到极度焦虑的时期。据推测，这在当局的心态中起了很大作用。他们认为西班牙在爱尔兰登陆或其他什么的、由西班牙煽动的叛乱可能会蔓延到英格兰。事实上，现在我想起来，我的意思是，历史上一直有这样的人。我的意思是，我不知道，你们的兰伯特·西姆内尔和你们的帕金·沃贝克
and all these characters, something starts in Dublin and then it comes to, I mean, they must have the sort of Henry VII landing at Milford Haven in Wales and then marching to England. That must be on their minds the whole time, is it? Oh, it's not for no reason that there are worries about security in all of this. And you can see it later. The Spanish Armada, 1588,
以及所有这些人物，有些事情始于都柏林，然后传到……我的意思是，他们肯定会想到亨利七世在威尔士米尔福德黑文登陆然后进军英格兰的情景。这肯定一直在他们的脑海里盘旋，对吧？哦，对安全感到担忧并非毫无理由。你后来也能看到这一点。1588年的无敌舰队，
it's coming up the west coast of Ireland. You see it later, as late as the 1790s, when the French are in the bay as the ballad goes. Well, 1916. 1916 again, with Germans who don't send men, but send guns. I mean, it's his reference to the Galant allies in Europe. I mean, he's talking about the Kaiser. Yeah, and we will talk about that later.
正沿着爱尔兰西海岸驶来。你后来也会看到，直到18世纪90年代，正如民谣所唱，法国人在海湾里。还有1916年。1916年又是这样，德国人没有派兵，而是送去了枪支。我的意思是，这是对欧洲“勇敢盟友”的提及。我的意思是，他指的是德皇。是的，我们稍后再谈这个。
I'm distracting you from the 16th and 17th century. Yeah, but it goes where you get dispossession and settlement for security, but then itself creates its own divides and creates its own war. So you say, for example, in the 1640s in Ulster, because not all the Ulster people have been cleared, not all the Catholics and people of Gaelic identity have been cleared from Ulster. They're left there in certain pockets.
我打断了你对16和17世纪的讨论。是的，但事情的发展正是如此：你为了安全而进行土地剥夺和殖民，但这反过来又造成了自身的裂痕并引发了自身的战争。所以你可以说，例如在17世纪40年代的阿尔斯特，因为并非所有阿尔斯特人都被驱逐，并非所有天主教徒和盖尔族身份的人都被驱逐出阿尔斯特。他们被留在了某些特定区域。
And so in the 1640s, there is a great rebellion. There is a rebellion, and there is 4,000 men, women, and children slaughtered. This, of course, has an enormous impact in Scotland and in England, and plays a part in what is probably the most notorious episode in the history of Anglo-Irish relations, which is the coming of Cromwell to Ireland. Yeah.
所以在17世纪40年代，爆发了一场大叛乱。爆发了一场叛乱，有4000名男性、女性和儿童被屠杀。这当然在苏格兰和英格兰产生了巨大影响，并在英爱关系史上最臭名昭著的事件中扮演了角色，那就是克伦威尔来到爱尔兰。是的。
Very much a friend of the rest of history. So Dominic is saying this in the GPO on O'Connell Street. I did hesitate a moment before saying that and I thought, sod it, just go for it. I'm looking at this as a hostage situation here. So I guess, I mean, in Ireland, Cromwell's reputation is, it's seen through the prism of Irish history entirely understandably. The reason that Dominic can say, you know, Cromwell is a remarkable and great man is that for us, he exists in the context of the civil wars in England and the aftermath of that. And the two are absolutely, actually completely snarled because people now call the civil wars the war of the three kingdoms, the three kingdoms being England, Scotland and Ireland. So to what extent do you see the kind of the story of Cromwell and the aftermath of Cromwell's invasion in Ireland as part of the kind of the broader story of what's going on in Britain and Ireland as a whole oh they're entirely intertwined and i don't think i properly understood this at all or even had a reasonable understanding of it until i read anna k's book uh restless republic which is
在很大程度上是历史常客。所以多米尼克是在奥康奈尔街的邮政总局说这番话的。我在说出这句话之前确实犹豫了一会儿，然后我想，管他呢，豁出去了。我在这里把这看作是一场人质劫持。所以我想，我的意思是，在爱尔兰，克伦威尔的名声，完全可以理解地是通过爱尔兰历史的棱镜来看待的。多米尼克之所以能说出“克伦威尔是一个卓越而伟人”这样的话，是因为对我们而言，他存在于英格兰内战及其后果的背景之中。而这两者实际上完全纠缠在一起，因为人们现在将内战称为“三个王国的战争”，这三个王国即英格兰、苏格兰和爱尔兰。那么，你在多大程度上将克伦威尔的故事以及克伦威尔入侵爱尔兰之后的余波，视为整体上英国和爱尔兰正在发生的宏大故事的一部分？哦，它们完全交织在一起，而且我认为我根本没有真正理解这一点，甚至在阅读安娜·凯的书《不安的共和国》之前都没有对它有一个合理的理解，那本书
just an outstanding piece of work we've had her on the podcast so yeah oh yeah a couple of weeks ago i think yeah a few weeks ago so and well i look forward to listening to that the book itself is it's one of those books that you can recommend to anybody to read whether you're a specialist or non-specialist and i'm absolutely not a specialist in Cromwellian Ireland or in that whole idea. But it was fascinating to read it and to look at the place of Ireland in the Cromwellian story. And she's something really interesting in it that I hadn't thought about at all. And it's the reportage in the English press of what happened in 1641 in the massacre. And she points out that, yes, there was a massacre and there was no denying that. And I'm under no circumstances trying to minimize that.
简直是一部杰作，我们曾请她上过播客，所以是的，哦，是的，我想是几周前，几周前吧，所以，我也很期待收听那一期节目。这本书本身，它是那种你可以推荐给任何人的书，无论你是专业人士还是非专业人士，而我绝对不是克伦威尔时期的爱尔兰或整个历史概念的专家。但阅读它并了解爱尔兰在克伦威尔故事中的地位是非常迷人的。她在书中写了一些非常有趣的事情，是我以前完全没有想到的。那就是1641年大屠杀发生时，英国媒体的报道。她指出，是的，确实发生过大屠杀，这是不可否认的。我绝不是在试图淡化这一点。
But she talks about how the stories were embellished and made to be more than they actually were. And you can understand better than the nature of the arrival. Because it's not just politics, is it? It's religion. And Cromwell and his troopers are terrified of Antichrist. And, you know, they see themselves engaged in a war of good against evil. So they are doing it by their lights for the best of reasons. Yeah.
但她谈到了这些故事是如何被夸大和添油加醋的，以至于超过了它们的实际情况。你可以更好地理解这种到达的本质。因为这不仅仅是政治，对吧？这是宗教。克伦威尔和他的骑兵对敌基督感到恐惧。而且，你知道，他们认为自己参与了一场正义与邪恶的战争。所以他们根据自己的认知，出于最好的理由在做这件事。是的。
And they're seized with that zealotry of the position in which they find themselves and wrapped into what they believe, wrapped into trying to maintain and develop something that they fought for and that people have died for and are fighting for in existence, really. But none of that excuses or can properly explain the scale of the violence that was visited on Ireland. But is there not one other element, which is something we've talked about, which is the security issue?
他们被自己所处立场的狂热所控制，并被卷入他们所信仰的事物中，卷入试图维持和发展他们为之奋斗、人们为之献身以及为之战斗而存在的事物中，真的。但所有这些都不能成为对爱尔兰施加的暴力规模的借口，也无法合理解释这种暴力。但是，难道没有另一个因素吗，也就是我们讨论过的一个因素，即安全问题？
So all the way through the 1640s, I mean, the lead up to the Civil War in 1642 and during the Civil War, among the parliamentarians and among kind of godly English opinion, there was this absolute paranoia that Charles I is going to rock up with a massive Irish Catholic army. I mean, we've often joked in the rest of history about the Ladybug book about Oliver Cromwell. And there are pictures. A good man. A good man. A good man except for what he did in Ireland. No, no there are pictures man but a good man a good man except for what he did no no no it's a good man the conclusion is a good man and not except an island cruel and they accept an island is the one three word kind of caveats but in that there is a pick that's
所以在整个17世纪40年代，我的意思是，在1642年内战爆发前夕以及内战期间，在议会派当中和某些虔诚的英国舆论中，存在着这样一种绝对的偏执：查理一世将带着一支庞大的爱尔兰天主教军队卷土重来。我的意思是，我们在“历史的其余部分”节目中经常开玩笑说关于奥利弗·克伦威尔的《瓢虫》系列童书。里面有图片。一个好人。一个好人。除了他在爱尔兰所做的事之外是个好人。不，不，里面有图片，伙计，但除了他做的事之外是个好人，不，不，这是一个好人，结论是一个好人，而不仅仅是除了爱尔兰。残忍，而他们“除了爱尔兰”是唯一的三字限定条件，但在这其中有一张图片
always stayed in my mind there's a picture of the irish rebellion of 1641 and there's this sort of the picture i mean this is a sort of 1950s illustration is of kind of wild-eyed hairy sort of catholic men rampaging around with clubs and this sort of image now that image was absolutely what a lot of english people would have subscribed to in the 1640s and 50s isn't it i mean that's the image that cromwell's troopers take when they cross the they have this absolute paranoia almost about Catholic Ireland. That's a brilliant point. And it's, it's really, really important to remember this, the depiction of the Irish, not just by the 1640s, but from Geraldus Cabrances, Fiennes Morrison, all the way through to the newspapers that are now emerging,
一直留在我的脑海里，有一张关于1641年爱尔兰起义的图片，有这样一种画面——我的意思是，这是一种20世纪50年代的插图——描绘了那种双眼圆睁、满脸胡须的天主教男子挥舞着棍棒到处横冲直撞的形象。现在这种形象绝对是17世纪40年代和50年代许多英国人所赞同的，不是吗？我的意思是，这就是克伦威尔的骑兵在跨越边界时带着的形象。他们对天主教爱尔兰几乎有着绝对的偏执。这是一个极其精辟的观点。而且，记住这一点真的非常非常重要，那就是对爱尔兰人的描绘，不仅仅是通过1640年代，而是从杰拉尔德·坎布兰西斯、芬恩·莫里森，一直延续到现在正在兴起的报纸，
this idea that the Irish are in somehow almost subhuman, that they're uncivilized, that they're uncouth, that they're not fit really. The wild Irish. They're wild. They're wild and they're not just rebellious, but they're not really civilized in,
这种观点认为爱尔兰人在某种程度上几乎是次人类的，他们是不文明的，他们是粗鲁的，他们真的不适合……野蛮的爱尔兰人。他们是野蛮的。他们不仅是叛逆的，而且在很大程度上并没有真正的文明，
they're barbarous basically. And so that also feeds into it. Barbarous and papist. And which is a very potent mix. If you're sending an army across the seas. And it does help explain the context of what happened. But again,
他们基本上是野蛮的。所以这也助长了这种情绪。野蛮且信奉教皇。这是一个极具破坏力的组合。如果你要派遣一支军队跨越海洋。这确实有助于解释发生这一切的背景。但同样，
the scale of the campaign, Cromwell arriving in 1649 into the port here with 12,000 troops. And what he did, particularly in Drogheda and in Wexford was particularly brutal.
这场战役的规模之大，克伦威尔于1649年带着12,000名军队在这里的港口登陆。而他在德罗达和韦克斯福德的所作所为尤其残酷。
So just give us a sense of that for those people who don't know the story. So just very roughly. I'd slaughter on an epic scale to the point where one fifth of the population is dead by the time he's finished. Yeah. But it's not just Cromwell, is it? I mean, he's not there for very long, and then it's handed over to his lieutenant, Henry Ayrton, and then Cromwell's son. And we talked about this with Anna Kay, that there's also kind of almost Nazi level of population transfer,
所以，请为那些不知道这个故事的人大致讲讲当时的状况。简单来说。空前规模的屠杀，以至于当他结束时，五分之一的人口已经死亡。是的。但这不仅是克伦威尔的问题，对吧？我的意思是，他在那里呆的时间不长，然后权力就移交给了他的副手亨利·艾顿，然后是克伦威尔的儿子。我们和安娜·凯讨论过这一点，那里也存在着几乎是纳粹级别的人口转移，
of dispossession. People are rounded up and transported to the Caribbean to work as slaves there. It's a terrible process. But that again, I mean, that's the combination of the obsession with security and the religious dimension, right? That's the two worst paranoias you could have, really. If you don't do something about it, then this is the backdoor to invasion.
财产剥夺。人们被围捕并运送到加勒比海去那里当奴隶。这是一个可怕的过程。但同样，我的意思是，那是对安全的痴迷与宗教维度的结合，对吧？这真的是你可能拥有的最糟糕的两种偏执。如果你不采取行动，那么这将是通往入侵的后门。
But secondly, as you said, Tom, it's turbocharged by this idea that these aren't just your enemies. These are the forces of Antichrist. I mean, that's what Cromwell and his troopers believe. And I think if you feel that, and if you believe that, it opens the door to any manner of action. It creates the environment for any manner of action it creates the environment for a form of zealotry
但其次，正如你所说，汤姆，这被这样一种想法按下了加速键：这些不仅仅是你的敌人。这些是敌基督的力量。我的意思是，这就是克伦威尔和他的骑兵所相信的。我想如果你能感受到这一点，如果你相信这一点，它就会为任何形式的行动打开大门。它为任何形式的行动创造了环境，它为某种形式的狂热创造了环境，
which allows you murder it allows you dispossess and it justifies it in the name of a good cause right and what you see then it's not just what happens while he was here it's not just a slaughter it's the continuation of the conquest and dispossession where you get Catholics
这种狂热允许你杀戮，允许你剥夺财产，并以正义的名义将其合理化，对吧？然后你所看到的，不仅仅是他在时发生的事情，不仅仅是一场大屠杀，而是征服和财产剥夺的延续，天主教徒
and Gaelic Irish pushed the far side of the Shannon into Connacht and into Clare. But when we talked to Anna Kay about this, she said, because we said, you know, is Cromwell responsible for all the ills of English oppression in Ireland and whatnot? And she said, do you remember something?
和盖尔语爱尔兰人被驱赶到了香农河的另一边，进入了康诺特和克莱尔。但当我们与安娜·凯讨论这件事时，她说——因为我们问，“你知道的，克伦威尔是否要为爱尔兰所有英国压迫的弊端等等负全部责任？”——她说，你们还记得一件事吗？
She said, I wouldn't actually point the finger specifically at Cromwell. I would point the finger even more at Elizabeth I. So in other words, has Cromwell become a kind of avatar of a much longer and very complicated story that predated him and post-dated? Oh, absolutely.
她说，我其实不会把矛头直接指向克伦威尔。我会把矛头更多地指向伊丽莎白一世。换句话说，克伦威尔是否已经成为了一个存在于他之前并延续到他之后的、更漫长且极其复杂的故事的某种化身？哦，绝对是的。
Cromwell is the epitome of what is the process that's 150 years of conquest and colonization. And it's understood through him. And he has become that lightning rod for everything. I have to say it's understandable that that is the case given what he's done, but it simplifies the history dramatically. And it's much more complex than I understood Cromwell much better having read Anna Kay's book. Joyce's famous line about history being a nightmare that, you know, people struggle to wake up from. Cromwell is a
克伦威尔是一场历时150年的征服与殖民进程的缩影。人们通过他来理解这一切。他已经成为了这一切的避雷针。我必须说，鉴于他所做的事情，这是可以理解的，但这大大简化了历史。在读了安娜·凯的书之后，我对克伦威尔有了好得多的理解，事情要复杂得多。乔伊斯关于历史是一场人们挣扎着想要醒来的噩梦的名言。克伦威尔对爱尔兰人来说，
kind of nightmarish figure for the Irish, well, say for the Catholic Irish. But there's another kind of episode in the 17th century that has a kind of mythic resonance for Protestant Irish, which is the Battle of the Boyne. So that's a few decades after Cromwell's invasion. Charles II has come back. The monarchy has been reestablished. Charles II dies, is succeeded by his brother, James II, who is Catholic. Protestant England is not prepared to put up with that. James II gets driven out and gets replaced as king by William III, who is of the House of Orange.
是一种噩梦般的人物，嗯，可以说是对天主教爱尔兰人而言。但17世纪还有另一类事件，对新教爱尔兰人具有某种神话般的共鸣，那就是博因河战役。那是克伦威尔入侵几十年后的事了。查理二世回来了。君主制得以恢复。查理二世去世后，由他的弟弟詹姆斯二世继位，詹姆斯二世是一名天主教徒。新教的英格兰不准备容忍这一点。詹姆斯二世被赶下台，并被来自奥兰治家族的威廉三世取而代之，成为国王。
An orangeman. An orangeman. house of orange an orange man an orange man and he comes over and island becomes the scene of the climactic battle between william the third the house of orange the protestant cause against james the second and his kind of catholic cause and it's the battle of the boyne that is the kind of the decisive battle in that conflict i know that later in this series, Dan Jackson is going to talk about unionist culture and the importance of unionist culture. And right within that, that idea of orange being the colour and William of Orange arrival and the siege of Derry. Or London Derry, depending on which side of the divide
一个奥兰治党人。一个奥兰治党人。奥兰治家族，一个奥兰治党人，一个奥兰治党人，他来到了爱尔兰，这里成为了威廉三世、奥兰治家族、新教事业与詹姆斯二世及其天主教事业之间决战的舞台，正是博因河战役成为了那场冲突中的决定性战役。我知道在本系列的后面，丹·杰克逊将谈论统一派文化以及统一派文化的重要性。在这其中，以奥兰治为标志色、奥兰治威廉的到来以及德里围城战的理念。或者叫伦敦德里，这取决于你站在分歧的哪一边
you are you're very brave in saying that that's quite the move well we're batting for both sides here Derry
你敢这么说，这真是相当大胆的举动。嗯，我们两边都支持，德里。
I'll go with the siege of Derry so Dira in Irish so there is so much of unionist
我还是叫它德里围城战吧，用爱尔兰语来说是德里。因此，如此多的统一派文化和保皇派文化都仰赖于那个时刻。并且不仅仅是因为爱尔兰本身曾是一场基本上是欧洲大战的战场的博因河战役、那个史诗般的时刻，它还得到了捍卫。因为威廉三世也卷入了反对法国和路易十四的战争。所以这也是正在发生的事情中至关重要的一部分。这不仅仅关乎英国和爱尔兰。
culture and loyalist culture looks to that moment. And the safeguarding, not just for what it is in the fact that Ireland was a theatre of what was essentially a major European war, Battle of the Boyne, an epic moment. Because William III is also embroiled in a war against France and Louis XIV. And so that is also a crucial part of what is going on. It's not just about Britain and Ireland.
正是如此。这真的很重要。因此，这也是正在发生的事情中至关重要的一部分。这不仅仅关乎英国和爱尔兰。正是如此，这真的很重要，但它对爱尔兰过去和现在发生的事情的影响是深远的。它所创造和培养的那种身份认同感，爱尔兰保皇主义的思想，以及坦白说，1690年之后延续下来并在整个联合法案及之后一直持续存在的新教统治地位的胜利。这导致了，例如，爱尔兰的一系列法律，即 penal laws（刑法），这些法律限制了天主教徒对武器以及价值超过五英镑的马匹的所有权，进一步限制了土地所有权，不允许签订长期的土地
Exactly. And it really matters. And so that is also a crucial part of what is going on. It's not just about Britain and Ireland. Exactly. And it really matters, but its implications for what happened in Ireland and has happened in Ireland since are profound. And that sense of identity which it has created and fostered and the idea of loyalism in Ireland and the triumph, let's face it, the triumph of a Protestant ascendancy in Ireland, which flowed from 1690 and which endured through and past the active union through all of that. And it led to, for example, a series of laws, penal laws in Ireland which limited Catholic ownership of weapons and of horses valued over five pounds, restricted land ownership still further, allowed you not to take land
租约，从1728年起剥夺了天主教徒的投票权。这是整个爱尔兰的范围。这是整个爱尔兰的范围。它通过新教对政治权力、经济权力和文化权力的统治而持续存在，这些权力在1700年代这座城市真正建成的时候就存在了。这里曾有一个议会。当我们稍后散步时，我会带你们去上议院，它就源于后来的那个议会，现在仍然开放，目前由爱尔兰银行旁边的柯。这座城市完全是在新教
leases for very many times, deprived Catholics of the vote from 1728 onwards. And this is across Ireland. This is across Ireland. And it endured through a Protestant ascendancy of political power, of economic power and of cultural power, which resided during the years where this city was really made in the 1700s. And there was a parliament here. When we walk later on, I'll bring you to the House of Lords, which came from that parliament later, which is still open, now controlled on Pollard's Green beside the Bank of Ireland. And it was a city that was absolutely run on a Protestant
统治下运作的，以都柏林城堡为核心，无论是在文化、经济、政治还是法律上。那么三一学院呢？那里的三一学院是新教教育的堡垒，天主教徒被禁止入内。所以18世纪，我的意思是，都柏林闻名遐迩的乔治王时代建筑就是在这个时期建造的。所以这大概是财富的一种表现。都柏林是斯威夫特和伯克的故乡。所以这是非常非常重要的关键人物。但与此同时，你又拥有这种系统性的压迫。哦，你拥有将英格兰的
ascendancy with Dublin Castle at its core, both culturally, economically and politically and legally. So Trinity College? Trinity College there as bastion of Protestant education from which Catholics were banned. So the 18th century, I mean, this is when the Georgian architecture for which Dublin is famous is constructed. So that is presumably an expression of wealth. And Dublin is the home of Swift, of Burke. So very, very kind of significant players. But at the same time, you have this kind of systematic oppression. Oh, you have the sectarianism of England
宗派主义在爱尔兰重塑的新教统治地位，在这种地位中，天主教徒在军队、政治世界中所有重要职位上的排除——不是绝对的，而是大规模的排除。在司法界。在司法界。是的。
remade in Ireland with a Protestant descendancy in which the, not the absolute, but the large scale exclusion of Catholics from all positions of significance in the absolute, but the large scale exclusion of Catholics from all positions of significance in the army, in the political world. In the judiciary. In the judiciary. Yeah.
当然，在都柏林城堡，你拥有这样一个国家、一座岛屿，那里绝大多数人都是天主教徒，却被排除在所有权力职位或几乎所有权力职位之外。这种情况是什么时候改变的？这开始于18世纪80年代到90年代，受到法国大革命
And of course, in Dublin Castle, you have a country, an island, where the majority of the people are Catholic and are excluded from all positions of power or almost all positions of power. And when does that change? That begins to change in the 1780s and into the 1790s with kind of inspired by ideas around the French Revolution
和美国革命相关思想的启发。思想正在形成。但这究竟是启蒙思想，还是出于一种恐惧——尤其是对法国革命的恐惧，担心革命思想可能会蔓延到爱尔兰，所以，你知道，你需要……当时都柏林坐落着一个已经持续了数百年的议会。那是一个新教议会。当时的想法可能是，这里有一个机会，可以将所有权力收归自身，使其能够独立存在。
and the American Revolution. There's the making of ideas. But is it Enlightenment ideas or is it a fear, particularly of the French Revolution, that revolutionary ideas may spread to Ireland and so, you know, you need to there was a parliament sitting in Dublin at the time, which had been going for several hundred years. And it was a Protestant parliament. And the idea was that maybe there was an opportunity here to put all power to itself and that it would stand.
稍微回溯一下，在我们进入1790年代的起义以及《联合法案》之前。所以，汤姆曾引用过那句关于“历史是一场人们挣扎着想要醒来的噩梦”的名言，而我当时也在想那个笑话：人们在爱尔兰乡间小路上迷路了，他们拦住某人问去某某地方怎么走，那人回答说：“嗯，首先，我不会从这里出发。”我的意思是，这是一个巨大的问题，如果这是一个过于简单的问题，那就直说好了。但在哪个时间点，我们可以说：未来的流血冲突、深重矛盾以及所有这一切，从这时起变得不可避免了？换句话说，你知道，也就是天主教徒遭到大规模排挤的那个时间点，还是更早的土地被剥夺的时间点？究竟是在哪个时间点？
Just to backtrack a tiny bit before we get into the 1790s and the rising and then the Act of Union. So, I mean, Tom had had that line about you quoted that famous line about history is a nightmare from which we're struggling to awake or whatever and i'm also i was also thinking about that joke about the people who are lost on an irish country road and they are stop somebody and he says they say what's the way to whatever and he says well to start with i wouldn't start from here i mean this is a massive question and and if it's too simplistic a question, then just say so. But at what point is it possible to say this is where future bloodsheds, deep conflict, all of this stuff becomes inevitable, as it were? So in other words, you know, the point at which you've got the massive exclusion of Catholics, or is it an earlier point, the point at which you have the land dispossession? At what point is it?
历史是否走向了一个拐点，使得可怕的事情注定会发生？还是说这种思考这个故事的方式本身就是错误的？事实上，这一切从未是不可避免的？饥荒、20世纪初的暴力冲突、北爱尔兰冲突等等，难道一直都是具有偶然性的吗？所以，我不会回避这个问题。但我会说的是，这一切并非不可避免，但由于宗教与土地、财富、地位相捆绑的方式，以及这些因素如何进一步与身份认同观念相勾连，使得这一切变得极有可能发生。所以你会说是16世纪？我会说是17世纪。我会说，你可以从16世纪土地定居进程的延续中看到这一点。如果你看看贝尔法斯特以及它在
Does the history take a turn in which terrible things are always coming? Or is that just the wrong way to think about this story? And actually, is it never inevitable? And is it always contingent that there will be the famine, the violence of the early 20th century, or the troubles, or whatever? So I'm not going to shirk the question. but what I will say is that it was not inevitable, but it was made particularly likely from the manner in which religion was tied to land and wealth and position and how that then tied into ideas of identity. So that 16th century, you would say? I'll say the 17th century. I'll say you're looking by the continuation of land settlement through the 16th century. And if you look at Belfast and what happened with the expansion of Belfast in the
19世纪的扩张中所发生的事情——我承认我在这里跳跃到了很远之后，但贝尔法斯特在19世纪从世纪初的大约25,000人迅速扩张。正如比利·布拉格所说，它变成了一个像利兹、利物浦或曼彻斯特那样的北方工业城镇。这些红砖房屋直接面向街道排列，围绕着亚麻工业和造船厂而建。正如我所说，它从世纪初的25,000人增长到了世纪末的350,000人。但阿尔斯特中部的分裂在贝尔法斯特的街道上重演了，并且通过身份认同与宗教的这种捆绑，以及1700年代确立的新教优势地位，这种分裂在人们的生活中延续了下来。
19th century, and I appreciate I'm jumping a long way forward here, but Belfast grew in the 19th century from about 25,000 people at the beginning of the century. It expanded massively. As Billy Bragg said, it became a Northern industrial town like Leeds or Liverpool or Manchester. And these red brick houses right on the fronting out onto the streets, built around linen industry and built around the shipyards. And it grew from 25,000 people, as I say, at the beginning of the century to 350,000 at the end of the century. But the divides of Mid Ulster were remade on the streets of Belfast and they are lived on through that, by that tying together of identity and religion and the creation of a Protestant descendancy confirmed that in the 1700s.
但回到1790年代，这里存在着一种状况：无论是英国政府对爱尔兰可能再次为革命法国提供某种后门的担忧，还是对过去所犯错误的一种默认。但开启了一个通过修改刑法来推进改革的过程。是的。然后爆发了一场起义，正如经常发生的那样，当压制性政权稍微放松压制时，你就会开始迎来动荡。哦，政权感到害怕了，因为他们看到了一个在1790年代初建立的社会的激进化，这个社会基本上就是“爱尔兰联合人”组织。而“爱尔兰联合人”所做的事，
But to go back to the 1790s, there is a kind of, whether it's anxiety on the part of the British government that Ireland once again might provide a kind of backdoor for revolutionary France, or whether it's a kind of acceptance of the fact that wrongs have been done. But there is a kind of a start of a process by which the penal laws come to be reformed. Yes. And then there is a rebellion and as so often happens it's when repressive regimes slightly relax the repression that you start to get the upheavals oh the regime got afraid because they saw the radicalization of a society which had been founded in the early 1790s which was basically the united ir Irishmen. And what the United Irishmen did
就是他们寻求议会改革。他们寻求天主教徒的全面解放，他们寻求在都柏林建立一个议会，但他们被拒绝了。当他们遭到拒绝并被镇压后，他们在1795年重新浮出水面。我不知道能否说他们作为一个秘密革命组织重新出现，但他们在1795年重新出现作为一个秘密革命组织，但他们作为一个秘密革命组织在1795年重新出现，并前往了
was they looked for parliamentary reform. They looked for emancipation of Catholics fully, and they looked for a parliament in Dublin and they were denied. And when they were denied and they were suppressed, they reemerged in 1795. I don't know if you can say you reemerged as a secret revolutionary organization, but they reemerged as a secret revolutionary organization, but they re-emerged as a secret revolutionary organization in 1795 and they went
法国。他们去了巴黎。沃尔夫·托恩，爱尔兰共和主义的伟大圣人之一，前往巴黎试图获得法国政府的支持并派遣军队。他确实得到了军队。首先，一支远征军于1796年起航，只是恶劣的天气阻止了他们的登陆。所以那里发生了一次流产的起义和叛乱。他们决定在1798年再次尝试，有5万名叛军参与了这次起义。
to France. They went to Paris. Wolf Tone, one of the great saints of Irish republicanism, went to Paris and tried to get support
暴力事件主要发生在四个中心：阿尔斯特、韦克斯福德郡、康诺特和伦斯特中部，还有一支规模较小的法国远征军。《法国人的那一年》是托马斯·万·林gen的一本精彩著作，《法国人的那一年》。1798年就是法国人的那一年。
from the French government and get troops sent. And he got troops. First of all, an expedition set sail in 1796 and only bad weather stopped at landing. So there was a rising, a rebellion aborted there. And they took the decision to go again for 1798 and there's 50,000 rebels involved in the uprising.
他们在8月下旬在梅奥郡美丽的基拉拉湾登陆，随之爆发了一场叛乱，这场叛乱是血腥而残酷的，某些地区的叛乱分子还进行了宗派暴力，最终导致
Four main centres of violence in Ulster, in County Wexford, in Connacht and in central Leinster and a small French expedition. The Year of the French was a brilliant book by Thomas Van Lingen, The Year of the French. 1798 is the Year of the French.
到托恩被捕时共有3万人在冲突中丧生，其中包括被捕后自杀的沃尔夫·托恩，以及拥有极高贵族背景、成为英国历史上最后一个被宣判叛国罪的人的爱德华·菲茨杰拉德，这意味着他不仅被处死，他的家族所有土地也被没收。但爱尔兰历史的诸多悲剧之一，对吧，就是为了试图摆脱这种压迫循环之类的东西，他们却在做着
They landed in Killala Bay, beautiful place in County, in Mayo in late August and there's a rebellion and the rebellion is bloody and it's brutal and there's sectarian violence undertaken in certain parts by those rebels and ultimately there are 30 000 people dead
英国人最害怕、最会进一步加剧镇压的事情。因为从法国获得援助，我的意思是，这是让英国人感到最惊恐的一件事，会让英国人觉得，哦，这就是为什么爱尔兰人，你知道的，我们不能信任他们。他们总是会和法国人、德国人、西班牙人或随便什么人达成交易。所以这就是那种悲剧：他们觉得摆脱困境的唯一方法，就是去做那件最能激怒他们的压迫者的事情，可以说是这样。绝对是的。当我们到达1798年叛乱结束时，宗教已经与身份认同紧密相连。所以它是天主教民族主义，是新教统一派。当然也有例外，以及那些此后被贬低为“城堡天主教徒”的人，也就是说他们向英国效忠。然后还有这些新教不同信仰者，包括，正如我们很快会谈到的，
by the end of tone including wolf tone who was captured and committed suicide edward fitzgerald who very aristocratic background who is the last person to be tainted in english history so that means that not only is he put to death, but his family, who's all their lands. But one of the many tragedies of Irish history, right, is that to try and break out of the sort of the cycle of oppression or whatever, they are doing the very thing
查尔斯·斯图尔特·帕内尔，事实上，18世纪70年代以来“自治运动”的前三位领导人都是新教徒。整个过程中一直存在着例外。有托马斯·戴维斯
the British are most afraid of and will most fuel further repression. Because getting help from the French, I mean, that's the one thing that terrifies the British and that makes the British think, oh, this is why the Irish, you know, we can't trust them. They'll always make a deal with the French or the Germans or the Spanish or whoever. So that's the kind of tragedy that the only way they feel they can break out of this is by doing the very thing that will most provoke their oppressors, as it were. Absolutely. And by the time we get to 1798 and the end of the rebellion, religion is tied to ideas of identity. So it's Catholic nationalist, it's Protestant unionist. And there are exceptions and there are people who are denigrated thereafter as castle Catholics, that is to say that they gave their allegiance to Britain. And then there are these Protestant dissenters, including, as we will talk about soon,
以及“青年爱尔兰人”运动。但同样，有两件新鲜事正在融入其中，不是吗？其中之一就是源自法国的共和主义思想。这种思想认为，法国是一个共和国，
Charles Stuart Parnell, and indeed the first three leaders of the Home Rule movement from the 1870s onwards were Protestant. And there are exceptions the whole way through. There's Thomas Davis
英国是一个君主国。而且也来自美国。而且也来自美国。法国是一个共和国，英国是一个君主国。而且也来自美国。而且也来自美国。因此，共和主义现在开始与摆脱英国统治的雄心联系在一起。另一件事是对遥远过去的某种浪漫主义情怀，这也是我们本集节目开篇所谈到的。
and the Euro and Young Irelanders. But also there's two new things, isn't there, that are becoming part of the mix. So one is the idea of republicanism, which is coming from France. The idea that, you know, France is a republic,
因此，这也成为了爱尔兰民族主义混合体的一部分。浪漫主义的鼎盛时期，对吧？对某种神话般过去的虚构，实际上也是1790年代开始酝酿的这一大杂烩的一部分。通过这几个世纪历史的运作，你可以看到现代冲突的浮现。你说得对，爱尔兰共和主义非常有趣。当我们讨论阿瑟·格里菲斯时，我们会再次谈到这一点，因为爱尔兰共和主义并不是教条主义的。
Britain is a monarchy. And coming from America too. And coming from America. The idea that France is a republic, Britain is a monarchy. And coming from America too. And coming from America. So republicanism is now starting to be associated with the ambition to throw off the British yoke. And the other thing is a kind of romantic sense of the distant past, which is what we began this episode with.
它只是不是君主主义的。没错。但爱尔兰民族主义现在那种既浪漫又共和的感觉，基本上是1790年代的产物。它是浪漫的，它是共和的，它是革命的。没错。而且它是带有宗教色彩的。你知道，像往常一样，我们不得不比原计划制作更多关于这个主题的节目。所以让我们谈谈《联合法案》，这是英国政府对1798年发生的事情做出的反应，对吗？
And so that also becomes a part of the nationalist mix in Ireland. The heyday of romanticism, right? The invention, really, of a kind of mythic past is also part of this cocktail that is starting to be brewed up in the 1790s. And through the work of these centuries of history, you can see the modern conflict emerging. And you're right, the Irish republicanism was really interesting. And we'll talk about this again when we talk about Arthur Griffith, because Irish republicanism is not doctrinaire.
是的。这个想法是，我们能阻止这一切再次发生的唯一方法，就是把议会撤出都柏林，通过都柏林城堡从威斯敏斯特统治爱尔兰，我们在那里安插官员，并建立一个本应是单一制的国家。是的。由伦敦运营。在这个过程中，它将做两件事。它将巩固爱尔兰的安全，使爱尔兰人文明化，并将他们引入现代的生活方式，让他们明白归属感将是美好的。
It's just that it's not monarchist. Right. But the sense of Irish nationalism now as being simultaneously romantic and republican, this is a fruit of basically of the 1790s. It's romantic, it's republican, and it's revolutionary. Right. And it's religious. You know, as usual, we're going to have to do far more episodes on this than we'd been planning to. So let's get to the Act of Union, which is the attempt, I mean, it's the response of the British government to what has happened in 1798. Is that right?
但这也意味着，在某种程度上，这赋予了爱尔兰人民在整体英国和爱尔兰政府中的股份和发言权。前提是他们仍然是新教徒，对吗？不，是的，前提是他们是新教徒。所以天主教解放运动还没有发生。因此，《联合法案》通过了。第一次投票失败了。
It is. And it's the idea that the only way that we can stop this ever happening again is to take the parliament out of Dublin, to run Ireland from Westminster through Dublin Castle, where we'll put officials in and build what is supposed to be a unitary state. Yeah. Based run from London. And that in that process, it will do two things. It will confirm the security of Ireland and it will civilise the Irish and draw them in to a modern way and get them to understand that belonging will be fine.
爱尔兰议会曾就是否接受《联合法案》进行过投票。第一次投票失败了，尽管付出了相当显著的腐败、行贿、官职恩赐等尝试，我们知道这些在所有这些事情中都是正常的。档案文件中披露了所提供的恩赐规模
But that also, I mean, to a degree, that then gives people in Ireland a stake in and a say in the government of Britain and Ireland as an entirety. Provided they're Protestant still, is that right? No, yes, provided they're Protestant. So Catholic emancipation still hasn't happened. So the Act of Union was passed. The first vote failed.
因为这很奇怪，实际上反而是新教徒相当反对它。天主教徒则稍微更有热情一些。是的，他们觉得他们会把权力失去给威斯敏斯特，在某些情况下他们害怕天主教解放，他们害怕自己会被抛弃。所以实际上许多受过教育的天主教徒
There was a vote in the Irish Parliament on whether to accept an active union or not. The first vote failed, despite fairly outstanding attempts at corruption, bribery, patronage, which we understand are normal in all of these things. The scale of the patronage on offer is revealed in files in the
对《联合法案》相当热衷。一开始，他们绝对是这样的。之后发生了两件事。对《联合法案》是一个巨大的打击，那就是通过《联合法案》承诺的天主教解放并没有发生。好吧，所以英格兰再次让人失望了。多米尼克，这不是很悲哀吗？那是一个爱国播客，我们偶尔会举手承认。为什么汤姆·海·布里顿——他懂保罗——那是绝对的……有太多迷人的东西了，绝对太棒了。我们下次还会回来的，不是吗，讲述《联合法案》之后的故事，进入19世纪，关于自治。进入20世纪。然后一路向前推进，所以我们从《独立宣言》开始，我们最终会回到《独立宣言》的。
public record. Because that's the weird thing, it's the Protestants actually who are rather against it. Catholics are slightly more enthusiastic. Yeah, they feel they're going to lose their power to Westminster and they fear Catholic emancipation in some instances and they fear that they will be abandoned. So actually a lot of educated Catholics
但我们下次再讲。所以我们到时见。再见。再见。再见。byebyeishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。
are quite keen on the Act of Union. In the beginning, they absolutely are. And two things happen afterwards. There was a huge blow to the Act of Union afterwards and that is the catholic emancipation which is promised through the active union didn't happen okay so yet again england disappoints very sad isn't it dominic that's a patriotic podcast we have occasionally put our
这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外单集以及抢先购买现场门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。网址是therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
hand up why does tom hay britton who knows paul that was absolutely so many fascinating things that's absolutely brilliant and we will be returning next time, won't we, with the story after the Act of Union, so into the 19th century, Home Rule. Into the 20th century. And then charging onwards towards, so we started with the proclamation and we will get back to the proclamation eventually.
举手！汤姆·海·布里顿为什么认识保罗？这绝对有太多迷人的地方了，真是太棒了。我们下次还会回来，对吧？讲述《联合法令》之后的故事，也就是进入19世纪以及地方自治，再进入20世纪，然后一路向前。我们是从《宣战公告》开始的，最终我们也会回到《宣战公告》上来。
But we'll be doing that next time. So we'll see you then. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-byeishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
但我们下次再讲。那么，我们下次见。再见。再见。再见。bye-byeishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点点八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、额外单集以及提前购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。